Ivik:
Så den første halvdel af undersøgelsen handler egentlig om, at vi skal finde ud af, hvor godt designet viser information. Så du skal egentlig ikke interagere med noget her. Du skal egentlig bare svare på de spørgsmål, jeg stiller dig i henhold til det opstillede scenarie.
Så det første scenarie er, at det er i dag 27. februar. Og du skal forestille, at du er på gangen og kommer i tanke om at du har brug for at booke et mødelokale mellem, 9:30 og 10:30.
Ivik:
Eller undskyld nej 14:30 og 15. Derfor går du hen til det nærmeste mødelokale, og her lægger du mærke til tabletten foran lokalet viser noget på skærmen.
Og det første spørgsmål er: Er der på nuværende tidspunktet et møde i gang i lokalet?
Mia:
Ja, det er der.
Ivik:
Hvordan kan du se det?
Mia:
Man kan se på det her store billede, der står der er optaget.
*Peger på skærmen hvor der står occupied.
Ivik:
Super.
Mia:
Og jeg kan også se det her nede.
*Peger på timeline*
Ivik:
Ja.. lige præcis.
Okay. Hvem har booket det igangværende møde?
Mia:
Det har Mia.
Ivik:
Ja. Og er lokalet ledigt mellem 14:30 og 15.
Mia:
Det ser ud til, ja.
Ivik:
Super.
Godt.
*videoen klipper*
Ivik:
Godt.. Scenarie to.
Du konkluderer at lokalet ikke er tilgængeligt i det tidsrum, du skal holde møde, og derfor går du hen til nabo lokalet, som også er et mødelokale.
Ivik:
Nu skal du lige se bort fra, at vi har glemt at ændre mødelokalet heroppe, forestil dig at det er den næste.
*Peger på lokale navnet på skærmen*
Ivik:
Så er lokalet ledigt lige nu?
Mia:
Det er det.
Ivik:
Ja. Og hvordan kan du se det?
Mia:
Jeg kan se det på det store billede heroppe, og det er til kl 12 det er ledigt.
*Peger på available teksten på skærmen*
Og så kan jeg også se det nede på linjen hernede.
*Peger på timeline*
Ivik:
Ja. Okay. Nu stiller jeg lige et yderligere spørgsmål. Er der andre måder end de to du lige har nævnt, man kan se det på, hvis du bare skulle skule henover skærmen.
Jeg tænker farve og andet.. det var meget ledende.
Mia:
Ja he he he. Ja, den er selvfølgelig grøn.
Men det var ikke det der først faldt mig ind, nej.
Ivik:
Nej, det er godt lige at sige.
Okay. Hvornår er det næste møde i det her lokale?
Mia:
kl 12.
Ivik:
Ja. Og er det muligt at booke lokalet mellem 14:30 og kl 15?
Mia:
Ja, det er det
Ivik:
godt.
*videon klipper*
Ivik:
Ja, så anden halvdel af opgaven af.. hvad hedder det.. af det her interview går egentlig ud på at løse nogle opgaver. Vi har tre opgaver med til dig. Og du skal bare løse opgaverne så godt som du kan.
Du skal lige være opmærksom på, at det jo selvfølgelig ikke alle funktionaliteterne.. hvad hedder det.. der fungerer.
Ivik:
Så i nogle billeder vil der bare være indsatte værdier, som du bare i dit hoved skal lade som om dem har du sat ind.
Og bare vise hvor du vil trykke for at sætte det ind.
Mia:
Ja.
Ivik:
Giver det mening?
Mia:
Ja.
Ivik:
Så her har du første opgave.
*videoen klipper*
Mia:
Så må vi se.. Jeg vil have trykket der.
*trykker på Schedule knappen*
Mia:
Og så vil jeg tryk..
*Forsøger at trykke på time boksen, men det er ikke implementeret*
Ivik:
Det er så her hvor vi har allerede sat en værdi ind for dig.
Mia:
Nåh, det var der i havde sat en værdi ind. Ja. Så vil jeg nok tryk der.
*Trykker på host boksen*
Patrick:
Og så vil du så trykke på QR-koden for at scanne den. Bare lad som om det er sådan du scanner den. lige præcis.
Mia:
Og så ville jeg skulle have Ole med eller hvad?
Patrick:
Ja.
De er så på nu, som du kan se.
Mia:
Nåh, Ja, det var den der var på, ja.
Patrick:
Yes.
Lige inden vi går videre til den næste, så vil jeg lige spørge. Hvordan kan du så se at du har booket den nu?
Ja, det var faktisk også det, jeg lige kom i tvivl om her. Så vil jeg trykke hernede for at se om..
*Trykker på den bookede tid i timeline, men der sker ikke noget.*
nej det..
Patrick:
Det var ligesom bare for at sige, at den er den her blok er dukket op nu. Den var der ikke før.
*Peger på blokken Mia Prøvede at trykke på.*
patrick:
Det var egentlig bare det jeg fiskede efter.
Mia:
Her mangler jeg måske nok lige et eller andet..
*vrikker fingrene over skærmen*
Patrick:
Lille pop-up.
Mia:
Et eller andet der fortalt at du har booket.
Patrick:
Enig
Mia:
Fordi Jeg ville faktisk være i tvivl.
Jeg lagde ikke mærke til at den her nede den kom umiddelbart.
*Peger på den nye boks på timeline*
Ivik:
Det tager vi til debriefing bagefter.
Marco:
Jeg har også lige et hurtigt spørgsmål.
Var det klart hvad QR-koden den gjorde?
Mia:
Ja, den fandt mig.
Marco:
Ja, okay. Super.
Ivik:
*Skifter til occupied skærmen*
Sådan der. Og så får du nummer to opgave.
Mia:
Jeg skulle udvidde det med 30 minutter.
*Trykker på extend*
Mia:
Og det har jeg så trykket herovre nu.
*Peger på tiden der er valgt*
Patrick:
Yes. Det var sådan set bare det.
Ivik:
Ja. Og så får du de sidste opgaver der.
*Læser opgaven*
Ja.
*Trykker på end meeting og bekræfter*
Sådan.
Ivik:
Godt. Det var sådan set det.
*Videoen klipper*
Ivik:
Bare lige et hurtigt debrief.
Så når du kigger på din oplevelse her, hvad synes du var godt?
Mia:
Jeg synes, det var simpelt at navigere rundt i.
Jeg synes, at det her overblik, man har nede i bunden det syntes jeg er ret fedt.
Ivik:
Ja.
Du synes også, at det virkede intuitivt.. eller synes du også, at det virkede intuitivt nok?
Ivik:
at skulle gå igennem de forskellige funktionaliteter, med at bygge møder og så videre.
Mia:
Ja, det var jo meget simpelt og lige til.
Man kan sige den der QR kode del, ved jeg jo ikke, om man har tænkt, at man også kan gå ind og vælge en person,
Mia:
hvis nu man ikke lige har sin telefon, hvad hvad gør man så?
Patrick:
Det var også noget af det vi snakkede med Ole om i forhold til Bluetooth Presence.
Mia:
Ja.
Patrick:
Og det er klart en implementationsdetalje.
Vi valgte bare at tage QR koden med i prototypen, fordi det var det, der lige var nemmest at vise.
Ivik:
Ja, og så er det modsatte spørgsmål til det her, er der forbedringspunkter? Er der noget som ikke var helt så godt?
Mia:
Der var det, jeg sagde med, at man lige på en eller anden måde fik bekræftet, at man havde booket mødet.
Patrick:
Ja.
Så ved jeg sku ikke, så kunne det måske være fedt nok, hvis navnet på mødete stod hernede også.
*Peger på timeline*
Patrick:
Okay.
Altså kun arrangørene går jeg ud fra?
Mia:
Ja.
Patrick:
Okay.
Mia:
*Peger på timeline*
Fordi så ved man også hurtigt hvis nu den er booket, men man har de her tre møder, så kan man sige, okay, det var Svend der var der, og ham ved jeg, at ham kan jeg lige snakke med, og så kan jeg låne lokalet fra ham.
Patrick:
Okay.
Ivik:
Super.
Patrick:
Det er en god point.
Marco:
Hvor vil du have det til at stå siger du?
Mia:
Bare det her nede.
*Peger på timeline*
Mia:
Lige, hvem det er der har mødelokalet?
Ivik:
Ja.
Okay.
Ivik:
Jamen det er jo sådan set det.